une raquette une balle et quatre joueurs
sur le terrain
voici les principaux ingrédients d'un
match de padel à mi chemin entre le
tennis et le squash ce sport ibérique se
pratique en salle pour ce tournoi p500
46 équipes se sont affrontées au paddle
club de bois d'arcy
il s'agit du seul établissement
yvelinois où l'on peut pratiquer ce
sport en a on a environ 300 à 400
joueurs réguliers par mois et qui
viennent jouer au pad alloués au
badminton
et puis voilà on a on a plus de 7000
joueurs qui sont passés depuis
l'ouverture
c'est très très bien pour le club mais
aussi pour le paddle en général qui ne
cesse de prendre
voilà c'est sportivement ludique et si
conviviale qui convient à tous
concernant les règles on compte les
points comme au tennis en deux sets
gagnants avec tout de même quelques
particularités au niveau du service on
va servir à la cuillère sapin service
par an à la cuillère après rebond
ce qui est important c'est que la balle
rebondisse toujours une fois sur le coup
la moquette du clan adverse si on envoie
la balle au dessus du filet qu'elles
touchent directement le mur ses fautes
sport très populaire dans les pays
hispaniques le padel fait aujourd'hui de
plus en plus d'adeptes en france c'est
vachement plus ludique et on peut
vachement plus s'amuser sans forcément
avoir un niveau de langue pour moi j'ai
pas un gros niveau de tennis ni de padel
d'ailleurs mais je m'éclate
la clac à en faire je viens au moins
quatre fois par semaine actuellement
5300 personnes font partie du circuit
français
le nombre de pratiquants dépasse quant à
lui les 50000